what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and we just
watched the miss marvel finale and
before we get started we are going to be
talking about spoilers so you have been
warned and now that that's out of the
way let's talk about the fact that
basically mutants now exist in the mcu
in the miss marvel finale they have
officially set up mutants and if you're
wondering how exactly they did this in
the finale well besides bruno saying the
word mutation there was one easter egg
that made it extremely clear that kamala
is indeed a mutant but you might have
missed this weren't paying attention
close enough and of course we are going
to talk about that post credit scene we
have a cameo from captain marvel carol
danvers and she shows up in the room of
a fan that adores her of course it's not
just a fan it is miss marvel's room and
a lot of people are confused about how
exactly this all happened but don't
worry we're going to break down
everything you need to know in this
video so as far as the mutants being
confirmed in the mcu is concerned let's
talk about how marvel studios just did
that in miss marvel episode six in the
finale at the very end where it says one
week later bruno talks to kamala and he
says there's something that he needs to
tell her and he tells her okay so i went
back and i looked at your genetic makeup
again kamala makes a joke and says bruno
you can call me if you're bored you know
instead of doing things like that
looking into her genetic makeup but
bruno says no i did it because amir her
brother kept asking if he might have
powers too if these were genetic and in
this research that bruno did on kamal's
genetics he actually found something and
he says that he thinks they might have
been wrong the entire time on their
guesses on what was happening with
kamal's genetics and the bengal
activating powers within her kamala asks
well what do you mean he then says so we
know why you have access to the nor and
how you can wield it what he is
referring to here is her and her family
being clandestines that is her family
genetics but he says but when i compared
you to the rest of your family something
still seemed off he says kamala there's
something different in your genes and i
think a lot of people thought that they
were going to explain that kamala is
actually an inhuman like she is in the
comics however that's not the rapid go
down instead bruno says there's
something different about your genes
like a mutation now this is obviously a
mutant reference but this is not the
easter egg that i am talking about the
big easter egg that confirms that kamala
khan is a mutant and that this is a
setup for the mutants and the x-men is
the theme song that they play right as
bruno says a mutation if you listen
carefully right here when bruno says a
mutation you can hear the theme song
from the x-men animated series play take
a listen here
in your genes
like
like a mutation
this is very obvious because nothing
else sounds like this in the background
music playing it's a very hard synth
that kind of comes out of nowhere and
then fades away and we don't hear
anything else like this in the
background music not before not after
and if you're wondering if this really
is the x-men animated series theme yes
yes it very much is take a listen to it
that
is straight from the animated theme
[Music]
so this is the easter egg right here
that actually confirms that the mutants
are now in the mcu kamala khan has
actually been changed from an inhuman to
a mutant but the mutants are now
officially in the mcu and what's
actually really funny about this and
kind of perfect is the timing of it all
check this out kevin feige in a recent
interview has talked about how we're
going to see pretty soon how everything
is going to kind of start to come
together and he also said that pretty
soon we were going to be teased about
the mcu's future this is most likely
what he was talking about the mutants
and the fact that miss marvel was going
to reveal the mutants in the mcu also
check this out the last thing that kevin
feige said at san diego comic-con the
last time that marvel studios attended
in 2019 was about the mutants literally
one of the last things that he said
before ending the hall h marvel studios
panel was about the fantastic fort and
the mutants take a listen here
[Applause]
there's no time left to talk about
mutants
now kevin feige immediately after this
in an interview did say that mutants and
x-men were interchangeable when he says
mutants he means the x-men but keep in
mind the x-men is a team so yes we're
going to get mutants in the mcu before
we get the x-men team in the mcu so the
last thing kevin feige said at the last
comic con that marvel studios attended
was about the mutants and now ten days
before the next comic con that marvel
studios is confirmed to be attending at
hall h miss marvel drops the word
mutations and it even plays the theme
from the x-men animated series
this all seems way too coincidental and
i'm hoping that marvel studios is going
to address the mutants in the mcu at san
diego comic-con in just 10 days during
their hall age panel this is the biggest
easter egg that we've gotten in a very
long time and it's super exciting so let
me know what you think about it in the
comments down below and now let's talk
about that post-credit scene with
captain marvel i know a lot of fans are
confused about what was happening but if
we think about how kamala's great
grandmother discovered the bengal things
start to become more clear when kamala's
great grandmother aisha got the bengal
she took it from a blue arm confirming
that the person that she took it from
even though they were dead was a cree
and they also mentioned that somebody
told them that there were supposed to be
two bengals but they only found one so
the fact that the bengal was taken from
a cree arm and there was supposed to be
two of them confirms that these are
actually the nega bands now in the
comics the nega bands are an ancient
cree relic so the fact that they found
the bengal from a cree makes perfect
sense also not to mention captain marvel
carol danvers thought that she was a
cree so obviously big connections to
captain marvel as well and this
post-credits scene set up the marvels
which is captain marvel 2 which we know
ms marvel is going to be a part of now
as far as how miss marvel and carol
danvers managed to switch places this
can also be linked to the nega bands in
the comics captain marvel not captain
marvel but captain mar dash vel was
given the nega bands by the cree supreme
intelligence but the nega bands would
end up trapping captain marvel inside of
the negative zone however back on earth
rick jones found a pair of mega bands
himself and using the nega bands he was
able to swap places with captain marvel
so it seems the nega bands have a power
that lets the users of the mega bands
switch places now again they did
establish that there were supposed to be
two bengals in the mcu but they only
found one so we can assume that the
other is out there somewhere and since
acree had one of them it's safe to
assume that a cree has the other and we
know that captain marvel used to be a
cree even though she was kind of
brainwashed as one but we also know that
captain marvel is out there in the
cosmos doing whatever right now she's
being a cosmic avenger so what most
likely has happened here is that captain
marvel came in contact with the other
bengal and something was activated that
caused the two of them to switch places
in fact if we take a look at carol
danvers in this post-credits scene it
does seem like she has something on her
wrist she is wearing gloves but on her
left hand it does look like there's
something metal on there now it doesn't
exactly look like a bangle not like the
one kamala has but it could have been
reshaped or reformed somehow after all
these relics are ancient and they are
technically magic so they could have
definitely been reshaped also if you
think about the post credit from chiang
chi captain marvel gets some sort of a
call some sort of a distress signal that
makes her have to leave the call this
could be related to the other bengal
which she eventually goes to check out
that causes her to swap places with miss
marvel now she doesn't look exactly the
same as she does in this post credit
scene here but perhaps it doesn't happen
immediately after it may happen just a
little bit after that shang chipos
credit scene but i would bet that these
two are connected so that is a setup for
the marvel slash captain marvel 2 and
the mutants are now in the mcu so let me
know what you think about this news in
the comments down below how excited are
you for the mutants in the mcu
and for captain marvel 2. don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel news and easter eggs you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram for live updates and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof